everywhere nurses are on the front lines
of the fight against kovit 19 often
putting their very lives
at risk to save others but the fight has
taken
a heavy toll a nurse advocacy group is
now sounding the alarm about a so-called
covet-19 effect
that could impact nursing for years to
come
you saw a lot of people die in one shift
and at that time we had up to 10 12
deaths per night
it was terrible it was terrible
on every shift the bell that rang to
move the bodies of the patients to the
cold room
was ringing almost every two hours every
hour
it was very severe psychological stress
mexican nurse alina salgado lost a lot
to covid
even her father who contracted the virus
working as a doctor
it was so hard that was the most painful
experience
besides seeing so many people die
like her many of the almost 28 million
nurses around the world
are working under huge pressure at the
forefront of the pandemic
there are so many people who's going to
die that's the reality
it's a really a really tough situation
we are fighting and we'll fight
the international council of nurses says
mass trauma among nurses is a global
phenomenon
the organization wants the pandemic to
mark a turning point for healthcare
[Music]
now 12 plus months into the pandemic we
should be seeing
those applause turn into action
we need to see hard investment in the
protection
the support the development of our
nursing and
our health care workforce not just
for the sake of our health systems but
for our national safety and security the
icn says at least 3 000 nurses around
the world have died from covert 19.
the real number is thought to be in the
tens of thousands
that was the most difficult thing
having our colleagues we have our
colleagues
many of them who died colleagues were
not sick
a person you were talking to the
previous day the following day the
person is no more
in some countries the heavy toll of the
pandemic has prompted a growing number
of nurses to leave the profession
but for many it's reinforced their
dedication to the job
there is a profession it's a profession
where you are there from the moment
life comes into the world until the
moment
it leaves again